[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de parlement
hebdo l'émission qui revient sur les
temps forts de la semaine à l'assemblée
et au sénat et nous accueillons cette
semaine tu as nous accueillons hervé
marseille bonjour hervé marseille
bonjour vous êtes président du groupe
union centriste au sénat absolument
garder marseille on va commencer par
vous présenter vous êtes né à abbeville
dans la somme
mais des hauts de france aux hauts de
seine il n'y a qu'un pas puisque vous
êtes élu du 92 depuis pas loin de 30 ans
maire de meudon pendant 18 ans sénateur
des hauts-de-seine vous êtes aujourd'hui
président du groupe union centriste au
sénat
votre signe distinctif hervé marseille
votre sens de l'humour et vos talents
d'imitateur vous en feriez pas une là
n'ont pas aujourd'hui j'ai pas la voix
sable un petit nicolas sarkozy non non
non j'ai beaucoup d'amis donc je vais
pas les perdre
ah bon en tout cas c'est bien votre voix
qu'on va donc entendre aujourd'hui pour
revenir sur l'actualité parlementaire
avec à la une cette semaine la colère
noire des sénateurs après les annonces
des manuels macron pour l'hôpital public
alors qu'il était justement en train de
débattre
j'ai de la sécu sortir du glyphosate ce
n'est pas si facile et c'est coûteux
conclusions d'un rapport parlementaire
remis cette semaine
et puis on reviendra sur la guerre de
positions entre la ministre elisabeth
bornes et le président d'edf sur le
nucléaire et on passe au premier thème
de cette émission
l'examen interrompue du budget de la
sécu
[Musique]
jeudi alors que le personnel hospitalier
étaient dans la rue emmanuel macron a
pris la parole
il a annoncé un plan d'urgence qui sera
dévoilée par le premier ministre
mercredi prochain seulement soit
théoriquement au lendemain du vote
solennel du projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale à la chambre
haute un tempo qui a provoqué la colère
du sénat et la fin des débats
quand un call mais pour le président de
la république
il s'agissait d'étendre la colère des
personnels de l'hôpital en déplacement
dans la marne
il annonce un large plan avec davantage
de moyens j'ai demandé au gouvernement à
la ministre de la santé
plusieurs de ses collègues est sous
l'autorité du premier ministre de
travailler avec vigueur pour un plan
d'action renforcé et des décisions
fortes qui feront annoncée par le
premier ministre au sortir du conseil
des ministres de mercredi prochain au
même moment au sénat le son des
parlementaires ne fait qu'un tour
la gauche demande une interruption de
séance mais l'examen du texte ne reprend
pas la conférence des présidents est
convoqué à la sortie de l'hémicycle
les sénateurs ne cachent pas leur colère
c'est outrageant pour les parlementaires
que ce soit l'assemblée nationale ou au
sénat
et c'est d'autant plus outrageant pour
nous que mardi soir nous avons fait une
réunion les commissaires de la
commission des affaires sociales tous
partis confondus avec les deux ministres
et que le deux ministres nous ont juré
le coeur sur la main qui ne savait rien
donc nous on nous prend pour des idiots
et eau pour des guignols on nous demande
de voter un budget qui sera démentie
dans les 2 jours ou trois jours qui
viennent
c'est du jamais vu dans notre république
et par conséquent il est normal que ça
hérisse un peu les parlementaires
au-delà des mesures sur l'hôpital pour
les sénateurs ce nouvel épisode est
révélateur du peu de considération que
l'exécutif a envers le parlement
on travaille pour rien c'est un théâtre
dont je pensais moi clé gilet jaune
avait montré même macron prison
république que les corps intermédiaires
que le parlement que les élus les maires
c'était important et que le risque qu'il
courait à organiser un face à face entre
le peuple de france et lui même étaient
quand même dangereux
les sénateurs en temps de taper du poing
sur la table avec cette suspension de
l'examen du budget de la sécurité
sociale c'est aussi le signe d'une
nouvelle zone de turbulences dans la
relation entre le sénat et l'exécutif
hervé marseille ils nous prennent pour
des idiots a déclaré alain milon bruno
retailleau part de théâtre d'ombrés vous
aussi c'est ce que vous ressentez
aujourd'hui oui c'est bien que le
président de la république prenne en
considération les attentes du monde
hospitalier mais tout ça n'est pas
nouveau
on le sait depuis que madame aubry a
installé les 35 heures l'hôpital va de
mal en pis et il lui était bon qu'on met
déjà des mesures dans ce budget social
on découvre soudainement qu'il ya un
problème parce que ya des milliers de
praticiens dans les rues de paris
bon ça date pas d'hier mais non on
aurait pu le faire avant et le tempo
pour le parlement et quand voilà 13 h au
moment où on est en train d'examiner le
budget le président de la république
annonce dans la marne qu'on va prendre
des mesures bon ça peut pas continuer
comme ça j'observe d'ailleurs que ce
même budget a été examiné à l'assemblée
nationale entend aucun député s'exprimer
dans la majorité annuel mâcon n'a pas
respecté le parlement en prenant en
décidant en panne à nouveau c'est ce que
disait le président annoncé millions
qu'on vient d'entendre dire de plus en
plus vous avez un président qui préside
il est le seul à décider le gouvernement
qui normalement détermine et conduit la
politique de la nation obtempère
l'assemblée nationale dans sa majorité
valide et puis après c'est la rue ya
plus partie donc c'est dangereux on
discute avec personne était vide
institutionnel pour vous c'est pas une
crise institutionnelle c'est un problème
institutionnel qu'il faut résoudre
on voit bien que le système ne
fonctionne pas si on le fait maintenant
avec le monde hospitalier encore une
fois qu'ils le méritent
on sait après la sphère des gilet jaune
que dans le grand débat la première
chose
la première chose que les français ont
mis en évidence c'est le prime la santé
ça touche tout le monde
les enfants les personnes âgées ne s'y
attendait pas forcément mais c'est ce
qui est en partie les gens ont peur
santé c c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
précieux c'est soi-même c'est la vie et
pour soi et pour ses proches et donc les
gens ont peur parce qu'on fermait
hôpitaux il n'y a pas assez de
praticiens
tout ça ne va pas on voit bien donc
c'est bien que le président dise on va
prendre des mesures mais enfin on a
l'impression qu'on répond à une espèce
d'éruptions qui arrive dans la rue alors
maintenant après demain si les
agriculteurs les étudiants les pompiers
ou les policiers disent ça marche bien
on va continuer à cogner reviendra on y
reviendra mais pour revenir à ce qui
s'est passé il ya une conférence des
présidents donc débat décidé
d'interrompre le débat c'est ce n'est
pas rien le groupe majoritaire les
députés elle rêve au sénat par de
démagogie de la part des parlementaires
c'est ce qu'ils ont dit dans un
communiqué qu'est ce que vous répondez
attendez on est en train on va pas faire
une discussion fictives sur un budget
fictif gé lire on nous annonce des
mesures fortes mesures fortes
ça veut dire que le budget contient pas
ces mesures là il faut bien qu'on adapte
les choses et donc travailler à la mine
le projet quand il arrivera c'est à dire
la semaine prochaine au conseil des
ministres et puis ça reviendra en
deuxième lecture au sénat
donc qu'est ce qui a été décidé c'est de
dire écoutez déjà au début de la semaine
après des déclarations dans le journal
du dimanche
concernant le agnès buzyn faut regagner
le bus a enfin qu'on faisait par
leicester à elle directement madame
busin avait dit mêlant mais tout ça
c'est pas vrai on nous raconte des
histoires vous en faites pas tout ça est
en discussion à temps le président
exprime des informations qui
correspondent à ce qui était déjà dans
la presse donc c'est qu'on s'est foutu
de nous et à partir de là on arrête de
discuter puis on examinera les projets
quand ils viendront dans le budget alors
justement sur le fond est ce que vous
soutenez donc les manifestants ils ont
été reçus par le sénat jeudi jour des
manifestations c'est une première aussi
pour recevoir ainsi les manifestants en
plein budget de la sécu c'était quand
même quelque chose de marquant pour le
sénat de faire ça pour la commission de
faire ça c'est normal qu'on entend de
tous ceux qui s'expriment dans le monde
hospitalier sebha syndicats catégoriels
c'est quelque chose encore une fois qui
touche l'ensemble du territoire
on voit bien que
dans les provinces françaises
aujourd'hui il ya une préoccupation très
forte parce qu il ya des
restructurations sur les hôpitaux et
cliniques les services et donc
évidemment il ya beaucoup d'inquiétudes
et pour qui est cette exaspération on
sait très bien malheureusement quand on
est amené à fréquenter le monde de la
santé que il ya beaucoup de gens très
dévoués qui travaille beaucoup qui sont
pas bien payés pour certains d'entre eux
qui ont plus les moyens de leurs actions
ce problème de l'hôpital public ne date
pas d'aujourd'hui
beaucoup de gouvernements qui ont essayé
dire sans succès là on a eu cette
séquence les annonces d'agnès busan ça
n'a pas suffi et maintenant les
nouvelles annonces attendues mercredi
qu'est ce qu'il faut qu'est ce qui se
prépare selon vous un plan marshall pour
l'hôpital public est ce que c'est ça
qu'il faudrait il faut beaucoup plus de
moyens il faut malheureusement là le
budget prévoyait une impasse d'un
milliard oui qu'on appelle l'ondam
hospitalier c'est-à-dire l'augmentation
des dépenses prévues cédait 2 1
oui été que de 1 en faudrait au moins
quatre oui il en en cas d'un réseau
hospitalier
c'est peut-être un peu beaucoup par
rapport à nos moyens faut rester dans
l'état il faudrait trouver 8 milliards
de plus chaque année pour pouvoir
répondre aux besoins naturels
est-ce que ça c'est possible mais il
faut discuter il faut trouver les moyens
d'adaptation
à l'évidence il faut remettre des moyens
pour la santé on peut pas continuer
comme ça changer de modèle
éventuellement d'inciter 6 pour
travailler avec les professionnels et
syndicats et vous pouvez les bonnes
soupes vaste chantier alors à
l'assemblée les députés en hf doucement
hervé marseille la discussion du projet
de loi de finances pour 2020 qui va
venir donc au sénat ils doivent d'abord
de voter l'ensemble du texte mardi
prochain en séance publique
et beaucoup de mesures votées et là on
voit des images de la discussion de
l'article 57 oui vous poser une question
sur cet article qui prévoit notamment la
surveillance des contribuables sur les
réseaux sociaux
est ce que c'est une bonne mesure où est
ce que ça vous inquiète c'est inquiétant
parce que la cnil s'est inquiété déjà de
tous ces sujets est ce que à force de
faire comme en chine la reconnaissance
faciale d'introduire des mesures
biométriques un peu partout c'est bien
qu'on prenne un certain nombre de
dispositions parce que il faut pas
oublier que le terrorisme était toujours
présent il est à nos portes puisque
jamais donc
on se protège c'est une chose mais il
faut pas que ça empiète sur nos libertés
c'est une forme de tract faux signal
numérique animé nos batailles au le
flicage en question la cnil a mis en
garde attention qu'on ne passe pas d'un
modèle de société à un autre
imperceptiblement parce que les députés
ont tous sont succédé à la tribune pour
dire attention attention respect des
libertés individuelles
elles sont menacées avec ce type de
mesures bah oui le sont déjà parce qu'on
voit très bien que sur les réseaux
sociaux
si vous mettez des photos si vous mettez
vous mettez en scène dans toutes sortes
de situations ben l'administration peut
en profiter pour dire ah bon vous avez
cette voiture mais où l'avez-vous
acheter mais c'est quoi
vous étiez en vacances voilà si vous
pouvez plus faire quoi que ce soit sans
fin des expulsions sans qu'on vous est
ce pire déconvenue soupçonne parce que
on va vous mettre en cause voire vous
demander des comptes immédiatement il
faut mettre des pare feux c'est une
société de liberté dans laquelle nous
sommes et serons le fond sur le fond du
budget requis et dont l'examen se
termine à l'assemblée dont l'examen a
commencé au sénat la droite naturel
parle d'un budget de renoncement c'est
ce que disent les l air est ce que vous
êtes sur la même ligne si vous êtes
aussi sévère non on n'est pas aussi
sévère parce que si on regarde sur le
budget la droite et le centre ont
toujours demandé des baisses d'impôts
qu'ils y sont la 9 milliards de baisses
d'impôts dont 5 milliards sur le revenu
bon la droite il centre ont toujours
demandé
la baisse des charges notamment sur les
entreprises la tendance est liée est lié
donc ce qu on pourrait remarquer
malheureusement c'est qu'il ya pas
beaucoup d'économies le baisse du nombre
de fonctionnaires
ça devient ridicule 47 je crois on
aimerait avoir les noms et donc ça
devient ça devient formidable donc je
crois qu'il ya un choix qui est il ya
des besoins
il ya des attentes on l'a vu avec le
monde hospitalier bah on laisse filer le
déficit
donc vous êtes beaucoup plus modéré que
vos alliés de la droite sénatoriale sur
ce projet de loi de finances mais non
mon essai de
sincère avec ce qui se passe quoi je
veux dire quand c'est critiquable en
critique mais quand il ya des choses il
faut le dire aussi
donc là c'est vrai qu'il ya du déficit
c'est vrai qu'on pourrait faire mieux
bon mais je vois pas non plus dans les
communiqués que dans lesquelles vous
faites auquel vous faites allusion
beaucoup de propositions sur les
économies non patience et connais ma la
droite sénatoriale néanmoins veut
transformer l'impôt sur la fortune
immobilière en impôt sur la fortune
improductives disent que taper seulement
sur l'immobilier eh bien ce n'est pas
juste ça relativise est d'accord sur des
propositions qu'on va discuter au moment
du plfr danger de loi de finances
rectificatif alors deuxième sujet à
l'ordre du jour à marseille le
glyphosate une mission parlementaire a
été mise en place pour évoluer la
stratégie de sortie du glyphosate
elle a rendu son rapport d'étape
[Musique]
aux commandes de ce rapport deux députés
de la majorité dont jean christophe
moreau qui est par ailleurs agriculteurs
les parlementaires demandent au
gouvernement de dire dès maintenant qui
sera concerné par les très nombreuses
dérogations à la sortie programmée du
glyphosate les précisions de natal et
guy noir pas facile de sortir du
glyphosate le monde agricole doit
apprendre à se passer d'un produit qui
représentent 30% des déserts dans vendus
en france et selon un rapport
parlementaire
la france ne seraient pas prêts
aujourd'hui ça n'avance pas suffisamment
8 et on n'a pas suffisamment de
visibilité sur l'évolution de
l'utilisation du glyphosate
donc il est difficile d'avoir une
stratégie de sortie du glyphosate alors
qu'on est incapable d'avoir une idée des
quantités utilisées des filières qui
vont être le plus lourdement impacté
premier obstacle calendrier d'ici le 1er
janvier 2021 l'uzège de l'herbicide doit
être interdite en grande partie sur tout
le territoire
mais les agriculteurs ne peuvent
découvrir les règles au dernier moment
le rapport demande à l'état de préciser
rapidement les cultures qui
bénéficieront d'une dérogation
d'utilisation en 2021
deuxième obstacle coup le glyphosate
c'est efficace et pas cher l'arrêt de
son utilisation alourdira les charges d
exploitation entre 50 et 150 euros
l'hectare en cause davantage de main
d'oeuvre et une utilisation trois à
quatre fois supérieur de carburant
mais le gouvernement de temps de
maintenir le cap
il réaffirme vouloir la sortie totale du
cliff aux attentes 2023 est ce que vous
êtes en phase avec les conclusions de ce
rapport parlementaire sortir du
glyphosate
c'est un processus qui sera long et
coûteux bien sûr et on voit bien la
difficulté le sénat n'a pas cessé de
dire avant qu'on interdise le glyphosate
il faut savoir ce qu'on va pouvoir
mettre en substitution
parce que les agriculteurs si on leur
dit en 2021 1er janvier et puis
définitivement 2023 vous arrêtez
glyphosate et demande qu'est ce qu'on
fait à la place on sait toujours pas
quels sont les cultures qui
on pourra pas utiliser le glyphosate ça
doit être fait normalement en 2020 donc
là encore emmanuel macron vous
dites-vous n'a pas écouté le sénat et
tous les appels de prudence est là pour
annoncer lui dire toute sortie qu'on
arrête le glyphosate
il ya un consensus pour dire que c'est
pas nécessairement quelque chose de bien
en même temps il faut qu'on puisse aider
les agriculteurs parce que l'arrêt du
glyphosate c'est entre 50 et 150 euros
par tonne de coûts supplémentaires va
pas envoyer les gâcher leur grande
échelle
donc il faut il faut mettre des machines
ou des produits de substitution tout ça
coûte cher tout ça n'est pas calculé il
n'y a pas d'impact qui ont été évalués
donc on part sur l'interdiction du
glyphosate parce que c'est très
environnementales écologiques sa course
s'arrêter là car nous voilà à une
certaine inquiétude de l'opinion et puis
en même temps les malheureuses
agriculteurs ils disent on fait comment
maintenant et vous savez qui utilise le
plus de glyphosate la sncf
parce qu'il faut désherber le long des
voies ferrées et donc au moment de
l'ouverture à la concurrence renchérir
les coûts de façon extraordinaire donc
on mesure pas tous les impacts mais tout
de même ne faut-il pas une vraie
politique volontariste en la matière
parce qu'on a on n'a pas arrêté de dire
que le glyphosate est mauvais pour la
santé
on n'avance pas la recherche n'avance
pas suffisamment il faut bien mettre des
dates butoirs hervé marseille
absolument mais il ya des dates butoir
mais qu'on travaille sur les méthodes de
substitution parce que sinon ce sont les
agriculteurs et les mails et les ce
changement les dates butoirs 2021 2023 7
8 ans ça ne sera pas le cas mais qui
n'est pas tenable
donc ça veut dire que manuel match on va
devoir revoir ses objectifs
on le voit c'est ce que prépare le
rapport en parlant déjà de d2 dérogation
on peut tous azimuts n'ont encore un
problème avec les agriculteurs
oui et comment vous voyez cet
accompagnement qu'est-ce qu'il faut
mettre en place un vrai plan
un calendrier qui n'existent le travail
et les scientifiques davantage il faut
travailler au niveau européen les règles
européennes qui s'applique et il va
falloir revoir le calendrier
vous l'avez dit les agriculteurs ils ont
déjà beaucoup défiler dans la rue
cette dernière semaine pour dire qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à joindre les deux bouts
pour dire qu'ils doivent faire face à de
la grille bashing donc est-ce que vous
pensez que pour eux c'est réellement
possible d'arrêter le glyphosate comme
vous parlais justement il du coup que ça
va représenter
moi je pense qu'il faut il va falloir
revoir le calendrier
ou alors prendre des mesures extrêmement
rapide en concertation avec les milieux
agricoles avec l'europe avec les
scientifiques ne sait pas gagner parce
que c'est un temps long le temps de
l'édition l'antenne on ne peut pas tenir
intéressant aussi de montrer que même
l'arrêt du glyphosate pourrait avoir un
coût environnemental c'est ce que montre
ce rapport des députés il faudrait
passer plus de tracteurs de machines
avec un impact significatif en matière
d'émissions de co2 explique le rapport
le rapport réussite aussi
l'association des producteurs de
céréales est ce qu'on peut vraiment les
crocs à ce cas pas aussi des lobbys et
celle de montrer ses seins bien sûr en
même temps vous ne l'avez dit si on
utilise certaines machines c'est
beaucoup plus de co2 qu'on va émettre
mais si on dit que c'est absurde donc il
faut trouver les bonnes méthodes dont
ckoi c'est le désherbage à la main ne
retrouve des jeux traditionnels on
trouve personne pour ramasser le raisin
pour les vendanges pour désherber les
champs bonjour aller à versailles on
passe au troisième thème de cette
émission parle encore un petit peu
d'environnement ont conclu avec le bras
de fer entre elizabeth bornes et le pdg
d'edf sur l'avenir du nucléaire
[Musique]
alors que la ministre de la transition
écologique demande à edf de réfléchir un
scénario 100% renouvelable
jean bernard lévy persiste et signe au
sénat il a continué de plaider en faveur
d'une part de nucléaire dans le mix
énergétique aux trêves états la france
se prépare à construire de nouvelles
centrales nucléaires affirmations
catégoriques de jean bernard lévy le
patron d'edf
c'était il ya un mois dans la presse
d'après lui il faut construire six
nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires d'ici 15
ans en france
coût total 46 milliards d'euros au
minimum
peut-être aurait-il dû utiliser le
conditionnel c'est en tout cas l'avis de
la ministre de l'ecologie recadrage sait
très bien qu'il est son point de vue que
je ne partage pas il se trouve que la
politique énergétique
c'est plutôt le gouvernement et en
particulier la ministre en charge de
l'énergie que je suis qui doit la
définir je la vis tu as intégré ce
scénario sur lequel travaille le
gouvernement 100% renouvelable et y
compris je pense indispensable que edf
réfléchissent aussi à la façon dont qui
peut être un grand acteur dans un tel
scénario 100% renouvelable comprendre
sans le nucléaire qui est pourtant l'adn
d'edf
oui mais voilà le secteur connaît des
déboires avec la difficile mise en
service de le p r de flamanville prévu
pour 2014
elle est reportée à 2022 et sa facture
explose 12,4 milliards d'euros pour
l'instant il n'empêche le patron d'edf a
plaidé une nouvelle fois en faveur du
nucléaire devant les sénateurs
nous continuons de penser que le
nucléaire qui aimait pratiquement pas de
co2 qui est pilotable le nucléaire a
toute sa place à l'horizon 2050 dans le
mix français c'est la position d'edf et
nous pensons qu'il a toute sa place aux
côtés des énergies renouvelables puisque
le gouvernement le demande
edf va plancher sur un scénario 100%
renouvelable pour après 2035
rappelant tout de même que la france
part de très loin à titre indicatif
l'éolien c'est actuellement 5 % de notre
électricité et le solaire à peine 2%
le renouvelable c'est donc aujourd'hui 5
% de notre électricité avait marre ça y
est ce que vous pensez que le 100 %
renouvelable
on peut y arriver est ce que vous y êtes
favorable c'est un objet
souhaitable au delà de tout ça ce que je
voudrais dire c'est qu'on n'y comprend
plus rien oui visiblement quand
j'entends la ministre il ya la politique
du gouvernement puis à celle d'edf
impression que la poupée marche tout
seul cas du cafouillage
voilà et donc on n'y comprend plus rien
mon groupe organise un débat au sénat le
11 décembre justement sur la politique
éco et l'énergétique pour interroger le
gouvernement
on n'y comprend plus rien et le
gouvernement ne sait pas où il va c'est
ça on aimerait comprendre ce qui se
passe c'est grave parce que il ya quand
même
et justement c'est quand j'entends ce
que dit madame borne pas ce que ça veut
dire qu'ils auraient deux politique
énergétique en france elle s'est fait
celle du gouvernement
donc on veut y voir clair il ya eu un
tas de cafouillage avec monsieur
hollande il ya quelques années sur le
même thème ah oui on savait pas très
bien tous les cinq minutes on ferme et
on fermait plus fessenheim on mettait
des affaires nationales voilà on savait
pas trop et pourquoi ce cafouillage sur
ce sujet la phase politique claire au
crazy
non mais attendez vous avez une
politique est normalement le principal
vecteur de cette politique cod oui bon
d'appeler edf déjà ses 35 entre
davantage d entre 35 et 40 milliards de
dette
chaque fois qu'on regarde vers
flamanville on nous dit ah excusez nous
il y en a pour 1 milliard supplémentaire
oui on est quasiment à quatre pattes
rafa quatre jours de nuit par des
graines en verrine clip who owns en
angleterre excusez-nous il y en a pour
deux milliards et demi pour augmente à
chaque saola doses augmentent c'est de
l'argent public c'est notre argent c'est
l'argent des français n plata en faveur
du nucléaire du futur à tous un
cafouillage continuer comme ça bon après
on nous dit bon on va on a un projet il
s'appelle hercules bien nommé conseiller
en clair on divise les activités d'un
côté les activités atomiques et les
autres activités de
une partie qu'on nationalise une partie
qu'on privatise sait pas où on en est
surtout qu'avec les problèmes sociaux
concernant la retraite en particulier là
aussi on sent monter l'inquiétude des
personnels sur sur ses projets après on
me dit vous savez ni un problème de
financement donc tous les ans on va
augmenter la facture électrique et on
voit bien les difficultés chaque année
quand venu le milieu de l'été à voix
basse on nous dit attendez vous à ce que
le coût de l'électricité augmentent
bon après le président d'edf dit on va
construire 6 p r alors qu'on est content
et la ministre dit ah bah non c'est pas
lui dire des choses pareilles
1 c'est au gouvernement de décider alors
il dit quoi le gouvernement c'est quoi
l'objectif est ce qu'on construit des op
r ou pas comment résorber la dette
c'est quoi le coût de l'électricité pour
les français non la ctc si vous savez ce
qui se passe dit le moi moi je vois pas
est-ce que voyez une contradiction entre
le fait que la ministre parle de 100 %
renouvelable dimanche
et puis il ya les objectifs de la loi
énergie climat cet objectif et bien
c'est 50% de nucléaire dans le mix
énergétique horizon 2035
ça c'est clair c'est dans la loi mais
alors là c'est pareil on se fait plaisir
la ministre l annonce des objectifs à
des dates je sais pas si on sera mort
mais après pour le 100 % renouvelable
mais c'est quoi le plan c'est quoi le
projet commence à se financer comme en
résorbe déjà les dettes existantes je
veux dire il faut qu'ils aient un
objectif clair et que le gouvernement
nous dise vers quoi on va et ce qu'il
veut puis comment on y va est ce que la
ministre salue aussi peut-être de ce ver
dire parce que c'est vrai que quand elle
est arrivée comme ministre de la
transition écologique on nouveau
voyez pas forcément se profile et puis
on voit aussi que l'environnement
aujourd'hui bas c'est un sujet électoral
c'est important sur les petites affiches
pas de l'art enfin le père bios n'existe
pas donc je veux dire à partir de là il
faut bien qu'on nous dise quels sont les
objectifs
est-ce qu'on fait des yeux pers ou pas
est-ce que c'est décidé ou alors c'est
qu'il ya un problème avec edf mais il
faut que le gouvernement clarifie sa
position et 10 ans enfin quelle est sa
politique et quels sont les objectifs
qu'est ce qu'on construit comment on le
finance
un mot sur une source d'inquiétude tout
de même le risque sismique qui a été
bien mise en avant à par le tremblement
de terre de lundi cinq centrales sur 19
sont en zone sismique est ce que ça vous
inquiète il ya quand même toujours ce
précédent terrible et mondial de
fukushima oui c'est vrai c'est
inquiétant on a découvert qu'en france
ou si on pouvait avoir des mouvements
sismiques d'ailleurs la centrale a été
arrêtée
je pense que c'est à sa préoccupation
jusqu'à présent cela mieux protégés que
qu'ailleurs et tout peut arriver la
preuve
mais j'observe quand même qu' il n'y a
pas des mouvements sismiques tous les
matins alors qu à flamanville learning
pour faire des points de soudure on a
des difficultés
donc il va falloir quand même trouver
des solutions eh bien merci beaucoup
avait marseille d'avoir participé à
cette émission la semaine prochaine
notre invité sera katia et vous ne sera
robin reda qui est député l'est
républicain de l'essonne très bonne
suite de programmes à tous chaque charge
[Musique]